j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré au poids politique
diplomatique militaire de la Russie
après 20 mois de guerre en Ukraine et
malgré les sanctions économiques les
sanctions internationales Vladimir
Poutine sort de son isolement le conflit
entre le ramas et Israël lui offre même
une fenêtre d'opportunité pour se
rapprocher encore des pays du Sud global
Samia dechir c'est l'un des rares États
où il peut encore voyager la semaine
dernière Vladimir Poutine était reçu en
Chine le président fait l'objet d'un
mandat d'arrêt international pour crime
de guerre en Ukraine mais depuis le 7
octobre les médias du monde entier se
focalisent sur un autre conflit celui
entre Israël et le Hamas une obine pour
Vladimir Poutine tous ces conflits
mondiaux sont des menaces commune qui
renforce la coopération entre la Russie
et la Chine si la Chine reste son seul
allié de poids la Russie ne peut pas
tout miser sur l'Empire du Milieu le
conflit israélo-palestinien lui offre
l'occasion de tisser d'autres alliances
en soutenant davantage le camp
palestinien Moscou espère prendre la
tête d'un bloc anti-occidental la Chine
d'un point de vue économique est
infiniment supérieur à la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine donc il y a aussi cette
volonté finalement de diversifier ses
activités et de pas de ne pas se
retrouver dépendant de la Chine donc on
a effectivement ce pivot vers l'Est mais
on a aussi la volonté russe euh de se
rapprocher de ce qu'on appelle ce qu'on
appelait avant les pays émergents les
fameux bricks donc Brésil Russie Inde
Chine Afrique du Sud il faut rajouter à
ça évidemment les les pays du golf et
certains pays d'Amérique latine et du
continent africain aussi et donc il y a
cette volonté finalement de faire de
rassembler les pays dit Non Alignés non
occidentaux derrière la puissance russe
dans cette stratégie de rapprochement
avec les pays émergents la Russie
cherche depuis plusieurs années à
s'implanter en Afrique jusqu'ici elle
l'a fait via l'organisation
paramilitaire Wagner de plus en plus
présente au Sahel et en Afrique centrale
mais la mort de son patron evgénie
Prigogine décédé en aût pourrait lui
compliquer la tâche l'intérêt d'un de
spadassin comme Wagner c'est que ça ne
coûte strictement rien à Moscou et que
ça peut rapporter quelque chose le
problème c'est que si d'orénavant la
Russie un peu la manière de la Chine
commençait à investir massivement en
Afrique alors il lui faudrait trouver
des fonds or l'économie russe
aujourd'hui se trouve dans une situation
qui ne permet absolument pas un
investissement massif en Afrique autre
obstacle dans sa volonté d'implantation
en Afrique le blé le blocage des
exportations de céréal ukrainienne est
une source d'inquiétude pour les
dirigeants africains qui n'ont pas
manqué de le faire savoir à Vladimir
Poutine lors du dernier sommet Afrique
Russie je pr tout de suite les invités
de notre débat Sylvie Koffman bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes éditorialiste
géopolitique au journal Le Monde et vous
publiez les aveuglés comment Berlin et
Paris ont laisser la voix libre à la
Russie livre édité par publié aux
éditions Stock Sylvain can bonsoir
bienvenue à vous professeur au Centre
d'histoire de Science Po auteur de
l'histoire de la construction européenne
depuis 1945 au presse universitaire de
France Anne bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes reporteur de guerre
indépendante spécialiste des questions
internationales notamment du monde
exsoviétique et vous publiez un
continent derrière Poutine aux éditions
point poche Mathieu croissandau
évidemment est resté à mes côtés Sylvie
Koffman la la Russie c'est presque jour
pour jour envahi l'Ukraine il y a 20
mois est-ce qu'elle est vraiment
affaiblie par les sanctions d'innational
aujourd'hui quel bilan on peut en faire
oui oui je pense qu'elle l' enfin ça
dépend de quel point de vue on se place
militairement non h elle se débrouille
visiblement on a euh quelqu'un c'est
Dmitri Mouratov le le rédacteur en chef
de nov gazietta qui qui vit toujours à
Moscou et et et dont on a publié
l'interview ce weekend oui c'est un
monsieur vraiment impressionnant euh
disait mais tous ces experts qui
disaient il n'y aura pas de munition la
Russie n'aura pas d'artillerie il n'aura
pas assez de soldats où est-ce qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui il devrai
démissionner et c'est vrai que on était
euh on avait beaucoup cette idée que la
la Russie n'arriverait parce que après
l'échec du de la première phase de de
l'offensive autour de Kief et euh il y a
eu on a commencé par dire ça va durer 3
jours et puis ensuite on a dit
finalement ça va durer 3 mois ils sont
nuls effectivement voilà et puis voilà
ça fait 20 mois ils sont toujours non
seulement ils sont toujours là mais il
il il ils relancent leur offensive euh
pendant qu'on a les yeux sur rivé sur le
Moyen-Orient euh donc les sanctions euh
bien sûr handicap l'économie russe ça
c'est clair même si le le contournement
des sanctions par plusieurs pays est un
vrai problème pour les occidentaux ça
c'est vrai euh le le pétrole par exemple
et le gaz ne sont plus
pratiquement ou très très peu vendu
écoulé vers l'Europe mais l'Inde et la
Chine en achètent énormément donc il est
toujours vendu voilà donc le le
contournement est un vrai problème pour
les occidentaux et quelque chose qui
permet à à Poutine de maintenir quand
même relativement à flot son économie
sachant qu'il a aussi des gens des des
notamment la la présidente de la banque
la gouverneur de la Banque centrale
russe qui est assez douée donc il a
aussi des gens qui aident à à à mettre à
maintenir ça à flot mais enfin c'est pas
glorieux et puis c'est vrai que les
Russes sont assez habitués à faire le le
Doron et à et à encaisser des conditions
difficiles syv faut peut-être même si on
l'a déjà dit parce qu'on parle
d'isolement de la Russie depuis depuis
20 mois sauf que c'est une vision très
occidentale de parler d'isolement de la
Russie qui sont les alliés de la Russie
aujourd'hui bah vous avez raison la
Russie est isolée par les Occidentaux
hein on peut dire ça ou bon ceci étant
ceci étant les Occidentaux c'est quand
même si on prend le format Ramstein de
cette ville allemande où il y a une base
américaine tout à fait notable c'est
quand même une entre 40 et 50 pays qu
Mme payocde
donc vous avez complètement raison de
dire que ce ne sont que les Occidentaux
mais c'est quand même déjà ça voilà non
parce que c'est vrai là effectivement
ils sont très très bons en com
làin
poutineinpin les gens du brixs et cetera
les Iraniens et cetera donc donc le Brix
on rappelle Brésil Russie Inde Chine
Afrique du Sud ça va et ça va grandir
l'annéee voilà et puis se sont ouverts à
l'Iran
ils sont très B en com et par conséquent
il faudrait pas qu'on imagine quand même
que ce qui est fait est encore moins que
que ce qu'on essaie de faire voilà que
ce que les Occidentaux essayent de faire
ça c'est le premier point
deuxièmement j'apporterai un un un
comment dire un disons un complément à
ce qu'a dit Sylvie Kaufman c'estàdire
que oui le le contournement des
sanctions en particulier sur le marché
pé rel existe mais disons en tous les
cas ce que disent euh les gens de
l'équipe Borel donc qui est le entre
guillemets l'équivalent d'un du ministre
des Affaires étrangères de l'Union
européenne ou ce que disent les gens de
son administration c'est que oui bien
sûr ils savent que c'est que la Russie
arrive à vendre son pétrole autrement y
compris à des pays qui ensuite le
raffinent et le revendent aux Européens
mais un leur but ou le but des Européens
n'est pas forcément comment dire
de faire complètement caler la Russie à
un point tel qu'elle serait aux abois
car de la Russie en effet arrive à
vendre du pétrole qu'elle ne vend plus
aux européens en particulier aux indiens
ou aux Turcs mais à des prix beaucoup
plus bas que que celui du marché ou que
celui qu'elle vendait avant bon voilà
pour ces nouveaux clients c'est une
bonne affaire oui mais voilà ça veut
dire
que bon c'est une histoire de verre à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide et et
enfin sur le militaire bon là je
m'abrite si j'ose dire derrière Philippe
gros qui est un un chercheur spécialiste
en stratégie militaire qui travaille à
la
frs pour qui en fait vraiment les Russes
ont un problème de stock c'est-à-dire
que comme ils ont énormément de stock
ils arrivent à continuer à donner le
change mais ils arrivent absolument plus
ni à moderniser ni à entretenir et que
là il seraiit en train de puiser dans
des très très vieux stocks quasiment
type 1945 donc et deuxièmement là aussi
moi je suis pas un expert militaire mais
ce qu'on voit quand même c'est que les
Russes ils savent très très bien
défendre là maintenant depuis 6 mois
c'est plus facile de défendre mais en
réalité ils avancent plus bon voilà on
on y reviendra an Nivas qui réunit
les les alliés de la Russie c'est quoi
un ennemi commun peut-être si je suis un
peu un peu simpliste un peu binaire les
États-Unis
oui encore faudrait-il définir qui sont
les alliés de la Russie aujourd'hui euh
pour je vais y revenir mais je voudrais
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit parce que
j'ai quand même passé à peu près 6 mois
en Russie dans les dernières dans la
dernière année depuis l'invasion pour
justement essayer de me rendre compte
dans la pratique si ces sanctions
modifiaient la vie des Russes et le fait
est que pour le moment elle ne la
modifie pas ou peu à la marge alors et
d'ailleurs les Russes s'en amuse entre
guillemets parce que elle modifie la vie
des oligarques russes c'est-à-dire d'une
toute petite partie de la population
russe pas du grand public et du du
monsieur et de madame tout le monde et
le fait qu'elle modifie la vie des
oligarques russes c'est-à-dire qu'elle
les empêche d'aller voir d'aller dans
sur leur ya d'aller ceci cela n'est pas
pour déplaire au plus grand nombre en
Russie parce que ça ça marche toujours
cette espèce de populisme le fait que et
Vladimir Poutine le sait très bien bien
sûr il en use et il en abuse le fait que
de de dire voilà je je je on punit
finalement certains mais pas tout le
monde donc il y a du du contournement
c'est clair il y a une adaptation de
l'économie russe à ses sanctions et ça
c'est inattendu c'est-à-dire que bien
sûr les opinions publiques occidentales
en tout cas les dirigeants occidentaux
plutôt attendaient un écroulement de
cette économie russe pour le moment
l'écroulement n'a pas eu lieu et s ve a
raison de de de mentionner le fait que
Poutine pardon est entouré de
technocrates qui savent y faire de ce
point de vue-là pour le moment mais bien
sûr plus longtemps durera la guerre et
moins ça sera stable maintenant pour ce
qui est les alliés de de la Russie on
voit bien que la Russie de par son
isolement bien sûr vis-à-vis des pays
occidentaux euh est en train d'essayer
de modifier ces alliances et il y a très
clairement un axe qui est un axe euh
avec la Chine la Russie et l'Iran l'Iran
on la voit arriver dans cet axe-l depuis
cette nouvelle guerre depuis à peu près
une semaine puisque cette nouvelle
guerre cette guerre au Moyen-Orient est
une obine pour Vladimir Poutine une
auine puisque un elle détourne
l'attention c'est-à-dire les médias
russes si vous imaginiez thomas était
fou de joie pratiquement hein je n'exige
je n'exagère pas en disant ça quand euh
au lendemain du du du 7 octobre tous les
médias occidentaux commençit leurs
journaux télévisés sur ce qui se passait
au Moyen-Orient et plus sur l'invasion
russe en Ukraine donc ça c'était déjà
une espèce de petite victoire
deuxièmement il y a ce problème pense
Vladimir Poutine que les américains
auront plus de mal à donner de l'argent
à l'Ukraine si la guerre continue donc
tout ça joue en sa faveur ouis Mathieu
juste on a parlé des conditions
économiques on a parlé des conditions
militaires le coût humain de cette
guerre comment il est supporté par la
population russe en
Russie
euh alors le même Dmitri muratov disait
que pour chaque soldat mort une famille
touche 12 millions de roubles
c'est-à-dire au taux actuel 120000 €
gigantesque voilà le par Rapp voà le
salaire moyen € c'est 300 € j'ai bien ah
ou oui donc c'est et alors dit
finalement les gens sont plus utiles les
les les jeunes ou les les hommes sont
plus utiles à leur famille morts que
vivants voilà donc
euh sil voilà on achète le silence parce
que en effet le le mouvement des des
maires de soldats comme il y a eu en
Afghanistan ou en Chechen n'existe plus
la d'une part la la répression est
beaucoup plus forte et et d'autre part
voilà il y a cette compensation
financière alors est-ce qu'il y a un
sentiment patriotique aussi ça je ne
sais pas euh traditionnellement il
existe en Russie mais je je ne suis pas
sur place pour c'est difficile de c'est
la Russie est est un pays gigantesque il
le reste évidemment une fois de plus
Vladimir Poutine joue là-dessus il joue
sur cette immensité sur le fait que tous
les Russes dans les coins de Russie où
reviennent les cercueils et qui sont
souvent des régions non ethniquement
russes toutes ces t tous ces cercueils
n'arrivent pas en même temps au même
endroit donc évidemment il n'y a pas de
possibilité de prise de conscience pour
le moment de tout le monde ensemble pour
pouvoir dire quelque chose c'est tout à
fait normal que ça se passe comme ça en
Russie aujourd'hui alors je reviens à la
question plus diplomatique de
l'isolement de de de la Russie preuve
que cet isolement est est tout relatif
en tout cas en dehors de l'Occident euh
cette visite de Vladimir Poutine à Pékin
à l'occasion du Forum des nouvelles
routes de la soie c'était la semaine
dernière on écoute le président chinois
parler de la coopération
russo-chinoise la Chine est prête à
travailler avec la Russie pour saisir
avec précision la tendance générale de
l'histoire suivre la tendance du
développement mondial toujours
s'inscrire dans les intérêts
fondamentaux de nos deux peuples
enrichir continuellement les
implications de l'époque pour la
coopération bilatérale incarner les
responsabilité des grands pays et
contribuer avec force au développement
et à la revitalisation de nos deux pays
à la sauvegarde de l'équité et de la
justice internationale et à la promotion
du développement commun du monde Sylvain
Cann cette relation elle est
déséquilibré entre la Chine et la et la
Russie oui clairement et au bénéfice de
la Chine oui absolument elle l'était
déjà
avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine par
l'armée russe
elle est très probablement encore plus
depuis euh on parlait d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure de démographie euh il y a un
pays très très peuplé il y a il y a
combien il y a 3 4000 de kilomè de
frontière commune euh il y a donc un
pays très très peuplé au sud de cette
frontière et un pays euh qu'on va
qualifier de vide avec une très faible
densité de population au nord de cette
frontière et si on s'en souvient dans
les années 2000 et jusqu'en 2015 environ
ça faisait partie des des craintes ou en
tous les cas des choses que que les
autorités russes surveillaient avec
beaucoup
d'attention le fait que
des des personnes venues de la
population chinoise pour travailler
pouvait avoir tendance à venir
travailler en Russie et à considérer que
il y avait peut-être la possibilité un
peu plus facilement que l'aurait
souhaité le gouvernement russe de
s'installer donc euh bon il y a ça il y
a évidemment une dépendance qui devient
économique pour les raisons qu' ont été
dites tout à l'heure puisque la Russie
devant se détourner de ses clients
occidentaux elle compte davantage en
particulier pour ses matières premières
sur la Chine l'Inde la Turquie mais
notamment la Chine et par ailleurs la
structure de l'économie russe c'est
quand même beaucoup plus que la Chine
une structure d'économie de type
rentière assez proche finalement d'un
pays comment on dit plus maintenant du
tiers monde hein on peut se rappeler la
situation changé évidemment mais la
formule de l'ancien chancelier allemand
elmou Schmid qui dans les années 80
disait à propos de l'URS que c'était la
Haute Volta avec des missiles nucléaires
bon donc oui la Russie la Russie est
dépendante absolument j'ai j'ai en
préparant l'émission j'ai lu le le terme
vassalisation à niiva est-ce qu'il est
trop fort d'près vous de la Russie
vis-vis la chinepport à la Chine euh
alors une petite anecdote c'est que dans
tous les aéroports de Russie aujourd'hui
euh les indications sont en russe bien
sûr euh avant elles étaient en anglais
et l'anglais a était remplacé par le
chinois donc effectivement on il a y a
et et ça ne plaît pas à beaucoup de
Russes bien sûr les Russes ont un
certain racisme vis-à-vis des Chinois
que j'ai pu observer quand j'ai été en
Sibérie et justement dans cette même
Sibérie sur le fleuve Amour auquel vous
faisiez allusion qui sépare sur
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres au nord
la Russie au sud la Chine euh j'avais un
un un un un ami russe qui qui regardait
côté chinois et qui m'expliquait où on
était exactement et qui me disait voilà
euh nous étions le grand frère de la
Chine pendant le RSS aujourd'hui c'est
nous le petit frère donc effectivement
il y a une espèce de vassalisation sans
bien sûr que ça ne soit dit sans bien
sûr que ça soit assumé ça n'est pas du
tout le cas chacun joue son rôle et
Vladimir Poutine là on l'a vu est allé
en Chine à ce forum économique qui
existe depuis une d'années et qui est à
la gloire desun d'un projet chinois mais
l'important pour Vladimir Poutine
aujourd'hui si je puis dire là où il en
est c'est de se montrer ailleurs qu'en
Russie parce qu'attention il sortait
pour de la Fédération de Russie
physiquement du territoire seulement
pour la 2uxè fois depuis 2022 là en
Chine et une semaine auparavant il avait
été au kyrgistan bon le kygistan c'est
un ex pays de l'URSS donc ce sont pas
des pays dans lesquel il se mettent en
danger mais symboliquement c'est fort et
une fois de plus c'est repris en plus en
cœur bien sûr par tous les propagandiste
de la télévision d'État qui montrait 24h
sur 24 à quel point Vladimir Poutine
avait été accueilli avec le tapis rouge
en Chine alors si on mais tout ça sont
des mots bien sûr ou évidemment si on a
souhaité organiser ce débat autour de de
de la Russie c'est parce que votre livre
sort évidemment Syvie Koffman et on va
consacrer un chapitre à l'aveuglement
européen notamment de de de Paris et
Berlin mais aussi vous l'avez évoqué
très rapidement tout à l'heure on va y
consacrer un chapitre entier parce que
ce conflit au Proche Orient il off de
nouvelles opportunités diplomatiques à
Vladimir Poutine on en parle tout de
suite avec Steve Jourdain qui nous
rejoint sur sur ce plateau rebonsoir
Steve le alors déjà on va commencer dans
dans le conflit qui oppose Israël au
ramas le Moscou n'a pas officiellement
pris parti non la Russie a refusé de
condamner l'attaque terroriste du 7
octobre il a fallu plus d'une semaine à
Vladimir Poutine pour passer un coup de
file à Benjamin netaniau pour simplement
présenter ses condoléances aux victimes
on rappelle qu'il y a pourtant au moins
19 essortissants russes qui ont péri
dans les attaques terroristes se sont
toujours portés disparu la première
intervention officielle du kremelin au
sujet du conflit a eu lieu 3 jours après
le massacre Vladimir Poutine s'est
contenté et bien de tirer un bilan un
peu froid un peu géopolitique du drame
qui vient de se dérouler
écoutez-le malheureusement nous
constatons une brusque aggravation de la
situation au
Moyen-Orient je pense que beaucoup de
gens seraient d'accord avec moi pour
dire que c'est un exemple clair de
l'échec de la politique américaine au
Moyen-Orient est-ce qu'on peut parler
d'un d'un revirement de la politique
étrangère russe dans la région ce qui
est sûr c'est que depuis plusieurs
années Vladimir Poutine et les
gouvernements israéliens successifs
entretiennent des relations de proximité
le deal pourra être résumé de la façon
suivante Thomas la Russie qui contrôle
l'espace aérien en Syrie laisse l'armée
israélienne opérer librement Moscou
n'empêche pas tsal de bombarder les
cibles pro-iraniennes pro bah sur le
territoire en échange notamment Israël
et bien ne s'implique pas dans la guerre
en Ukraine l'État hébreux refuse par
exemple de fournir le fameux Dôme de fer
vous savez le bouclier antimissile à
volodimir zelensk qui le réclame
pourtant depuis plusieurs longs mois la
Russie qui va jusqu'à se présenter comme
un médiateur dans la région oui la
semaine dernière Moscou a soumis une
proposition de résolution au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU résolution qui demande
un cesser le feu humanitaire à Gaza et
condamne la violence contre les civils
sans mentionner les attaques du Ham le
texte a été rejeté par la France par les
États-Unis par le Royaume-Uni et le
Japon de quoi évidemment donner du grain
àoudre à l'ambassadeur rus
écoutez nous regrettons que le Conseil
se retrouve une fois de plus l'otage des
intentions égoïstes des pays du bloc
occidental c'est la raison pour laquelle
il n'a pas été en mesure d'envoyer un
message clair fort et collectif visant à
la désescalade voilà visite en Chine
vous en parlez tout à l'heure Thomas
Vladimir ptine a affirmé que la Russie
coordonnait ses actions avec Pékin au
Moyen-Orient l'émissère chinois pour la
région et d'ailleurs en ce moment même
aux Émirats arabes unis objectif affiché
apaiser les tensions merci beaucoup
Steve Sylvain can à quel point ce ce
conflit au Proche-Orient offre
finalement j'employer le terme fenêtre
d'opportunité à Vladimir Poutine
bah déjà tout
simplement parce que il relègue au
second plan de l'actualité en tout cas
dans les pays occidentaux euh la guerre
en Ukraine oui voilà donc euh c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que et c'est peut-être pas le plus
important c'est c'est disons symbolique
c'est peut-être pas le plus important
mais c'est quand même important c'est
quand même important parce que
euh les européens ou les Occidentaux de
façon générale enfin encore une fois
quand on dit les Occidentaux c'est 45 à
50 pays euh h sont quand même
engagés dans dans un effort qui requiert
on va dire de la longévité de
l'assiduité et par conséquent de
l'information voilà hein et de la
préoccupation donc je pense que
objectivement le fait que le conflit ne
fasse plus la une de l'actualité et que
dans le même temps un peu partout en
Europe mais aussi aux États-Unis et au
Royaume-Uni on voit que il y a d'autres
sujets on va dire d'investissement
politique et militant bon ça peut ça
pourrait indirectement jouer sur un
questionnement d'une partie des
populations européenne vis-à-vis de
l'effort du soutien à l'effort
ukrainien voilà donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose
effectivement c'est que ça permet au
gouvernement russe on vient de le voir à
l'ONU en particulier mais aussi dans au
forum des nouvelles routes de la soie de
se poser en médiateur en on va dire en
donneur de de leçons en pacification euh
alors même que depuis 18 mois
maintenant l'image du gouvernement russe
c'était celui d'un gouvernement agressif
colonialiste et qui pouvait être accusé
de crime de guerre voilà donc ça change
beaucoup de choses quand même ci Hoffman
est-ce que finalement le le
l'opération militaire israélienne le la
ripost notamment aérienne n'affaiblit
pas aussi une partie des arguments
occidentaux and on parle la
façad oui oui oui c'est c'est la
question c'est c'est une très bonne
question parce que c'est le c'est le
grand danger dans parce que c'est aussi
une bataille de récit hein tout ça le le
récit maintenant a tellement
d'importance dans tous ces conflit dans
toutes les tensions mondiales et là le
récit occidental sur l'Ukraine qu' que
que les occidentaux avaient d'ailleurs
du mal à vendre dans dans le reste du
monde hein on l'a bien vu depuis l'année
dernière c'était la Russie commet des
atrocités la Russie et et l'agresseur
elle commet des atrocités dans un pays
où elle se comporte comme une puissance
coloniale en fait à une puissance
impérialiste voilà et qu'elle essaie de
coloniser qui est l'Ukraine et là on a
Israël qui à son tour bombarde des
populations civiles alors il y a une
grande différence quand même c'est que
l'Ukraine n'avait pas commis des
massacres de l'autre côté de la
frontière hein n'avait pas tué 1400
personnes en 24 he donc d'ailleurs on
parlait toujours dans en parlant de
cette guerre en Ukraine de la guerre non
provoquée he de la l'attaque contre
l'Ukraine non provoqué c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement l'Ukraine n'avait rien
fait et un beau jour les les Russes ont
envahi ce
pays Israël a été attaqué elle a le
droit de riposter mais cette question du
droit international du droit
international
humanitaire le fait sans respecter le
droit international ce qui explique
pourquoi les les les pays européens
notamment mais même Biden en allant à
Tel Aviv essae de convaincre les
autorités israéliennes de d'y aller
moins fort et de respecter les
population civile et de respecter le
droit international parce que c'est vrai
que ça donne des armes à la propagande
russe très clairement et la propagande
antioccidental je vous redonne la parole
tout de suite là-dessus va votre avis
peut-être sur le le le poids que la
parole de Poutine peut avoir auprès de
d'un certain nombre de pays arabes dans
ce contexte ça me semble intéressant
aussi mais le le le mais le poids est
énorme c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement
entend énormément de voix s'élever en
Russie et en dehors de la Russie dans
des pays qui euh n'ont pas euh critiqué
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine cette
question c'est à savoir pourquoi Israël
pourrait-elle voilà ce qu'on vient de
dire être exonéré du droit international
auquel les Occidentaux veulent soumettre
Moscou je voudrais revenir un instant
sur les relations entre euh sur le
rapport sur l'importance de la politique
du Moyen-Orient pour pour la Russie
parce que il faut remonter à l'époque
soviétique le Moyen-Orient a toujours
été extrêmement important pour le RSS et
notamment le le Premier ministre
Primakov qui était arabisant qui était
tout le temps dans la zone et Vladimir
Poutine en fait quand il est arrivé au
pouvoir il a voulu redéployer toute
cette politique à sa façon et je pense
et donc c'est vrai c'est un fait que
Vladimir Poutine parle dans la région à
tout le monde et ça il est le seul à le
faire et là c'est vrai depuis depuis 2
semaines ça fait 17
jours rend compte depuis de semaines
mais c'est vrai depuis plus longtemps ou
il açu le hamasésent Hamas par de fois
depuis fin 2 et au printemps 23 le
lendemain le surlendemain de de de de
cette ces atrocités commises par le
Hamas en Israël il recevait le
secrétaire de la de la Ligue arabe il a
effectivement attendu 3 jours avant de
dire quelque chose et ça chez Vladimir
Poutine c'est quand Vladimir Poutine ne
parle pas tout de suite c'est qu'il ne
sait pas quoi dire et qu'il ne sait pas
comment le dire et il a d'abord parlé en
disant euh en en n'ayant pas un mot pour
Israël et ensuite 3 jours plus tard
effectivement il a dit qu'Israël avait
le droit à se défendre mais je crois que
tout cela est extrêmement lié à la
relation personnelle qu'il a avec
Benjamin netaniaahou parce qu'ils sont
ce sont deux personnes qui sont depuis
très longtemps au pouvoir et Benjamin
naniaahou qui est affaibli par ce qui se
passe effectivement mais il y a un lien
entre lui et Vladimir Poutine qui
continue jusqu'à aujourd'hui en plus du
fait et ça il faut le répéter que
euh les Russes contrôlant le ciel en
Syrie
effectivement ils ont perdu 15 hommes en
2018 parce que en 2018 Israël a bombardé
une cible en Syrie et et évidemment les
Syriens ont rétorqué et quand ils ont
rétorqué ils se sont trompés c'est un
avion russe euh qui a été ciblé avec 15
morts et c'est depuis ce moment-là
depuis cette ce fait-là qu'il y a une
collaboration militaire entre Israël et
euh et la Russie sur le ciel syrien et
ça c'est très important et Lavrov était
à Moscou pardon à en en Iran à Tran ou à
Tran aujourd'hui donc le ministre des
Affaires étrangères russes était à Teran
aujourd'hui c'est bien parce que euh ils
sont concurrentiels hein au Moyen-Orient
c'est bien parce qu'il y a un souci pour
la Russie que les choses dégénèent alors
on va revenir à ce rôle potentiel de
médiateur parce que ce que j'entends
dans ce que vous dites c'est que
finalement Vladimir Poutine il parle il
parle aux deux aux deux côtés mais je je
voyais
réagir Sylvin can sur la question du
droit international oui alors moi je
suis ni spécialiste d'affaires
stratégiques ni spécialiste du du Proche
Orient mais j'ai été
frappé la semaine dernière par des
propos que tenait Bruno tertr le
président de la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique qui lui est
spécialiste et qui disait oui bien sûr
les bombardements israéliens sur la
bande de Gaza provoque un nombre
important de morts on pense 4500
personnes tué dans la population civ
ville en 15 jours
mais si on peut se permettre de dire
mais l'objectif de l'armée israélienne
n'est pas de tuer des civils hein et
rappelez Bruno tertray c'est très rare
dans le cadre d'un conflit de haute
intensité de voir une armée et un
gouvernement qui riposte donner quelques
jours à la population du territoire qui
va être visé pour disons évacuer
de ce que j'ai compris de ce que disent
les spécialistes
l'objectif qui est celui de l'armée
israélienne c'est disons de se de se
battre contre le Hamas et on sait bien
d'après là c'est Frédéric Anel qui était
tout à l'heure dans votre premier
reportage qui qui l'explique très bien
et on sait bien que l'une des
caractéristiques du Hamas comme
organisation paramilitaire et terroriste
c'est d'être extrêmement
avec la population civile et d'avoir non
pas des bases militaires dans des
espaces militaires mais d'avoir des
bases militaires dans des bâtiments
civils voilà bon encore beaucoup de thèm
à aborder donc je vais reprendre la
Mainz juste vous étiez pas tout d'accord
en Russie les bombardements qui sont qui
touchent toutes les semaines des villes
et des civiles sont fait de manière
complètement assumé un mot heureusement
que le but d'Israël n'est pas de tuer
des civils c'est c'est c'est c'est
normal mais le le fait je je là je
parley de la guerre au Moyen-Orient donc
ce n'est ça n le but n'est pas de tuer
du civil mais des facto des civils sont
tués oui on est d'accord he alors Joe
Biden qui est bien on va écouter un
extrait de d'une prise de de position du
du président américain conscient des
efforts de Vladimir Poutine pour
renforcer on va dire un un front
anti-occidental ou
anti-américain Biden Joe Biden il pointe
les points communs entre le Hamas et le
président russe écoutez
le Hamas et Poutine représentent des
menaces différentes mais ils ont ceci en
commun qu'ils veulent tous deux anéantir
complètement une démocratie voisine
l'anéantir complètement la raison d'être
déclaré du Hamas et la destruction de
l'État d'Israël et l'assassinat du
peuple juif le Hamas ne représente pas
le peuple palestinien il utilise des
civils palestiniens comme boucliers
humain et des familles palestiniennes
innocentes souffrent énormément à cause
de cela voilà pour cette déclaration de
Joe Biden syv Koffman sur le rôle de
médiateur de de Vladimir Poutine parce
que c'est c'est intéressant on a un Joe
Biden qui montre on l' on l'a on a
consacré la première partie de
l'émission en partie à ça toute la
puissance militaire américaine en ce
moment dans la zone en
Méditerranée mais on a aussi un Vladimir
Poutine qui qui parle à tout le monde
oui alors est-ce qu'on surestime son
rôle de médiateur
potentiel oui il a rien fait j crois pas
trop il est quand
même Anne soulignait tout à l'heure son
statut de paria sur la scène
international donc déjà un médiateur qui
peut pas trop se déplacer c'est un peu
ennuyeux euh et puis son il est il est
il est à la tête d'un pays en guerre qui
agresse un autre pays c'est ça le
décrédibilise quand même un petit peu il
me semble alors même s'il a des
interlocuteurs son rôle en Syrie c'est
quand même bon c'est pas non plus ce
qu'il y a de plus recommandable sur le
temp sur le plan du droit international
enfin alors
euh je je sais pas qui il y a d'autres
il y a d'autres acteurs hein il y a la
Turquie il a voilà euh il peut y avoir
des pays du golf
voilàatar pour les aotages mais même
pour pour essayer de relancer un
processus de paix ça c'est de toute
façon c'est pas pour tout de suite mais
pour essayer de d'ouvrir une voie
humanitaire au moins je pense que pour
l'instant les États-Unis sont plus
crédibles à mon avis et et et on plus là
et ont quand même un dialogue plus même
s'il est difficile mais on on on sont
les interlocuteurs des Israéliens alors
que je crois que la la position de de
Poutine à l'évolution de sa position
avec Israël rend les choses quand même
compliquées avec Israël il me semble et
puis il y a une forme de de cynisme
évidemment dans dans les les propos de
Vladimir Poutine depuis plusieurs jours
notamment quand il alerte sur les
victimes civiles des conflits armés
évidemment il en profite écoutez sur ce
thème le chancelier allemand Olaf
Scholz je suis plus qu'indé lorsque
j'entend que le président russe met
actuellement en garde tous les pays qui
font des victimes des victimes civiles
lors de conflit armé
il n'y a pas plus cque que cela c
Hoffman vous vous décortiquez dans votre
livre Les aveuglés 20 ans de naïveté de
l'Allemagne et de la et de la France
face à face au président
russse est-ce que cet aveuglement a en
partie permis à Vladimir Poutine de de
préparer l'invasion de l'Ukraine je
pense oui vous dites en partie vous êtes
prudent et vous avez
raison je souscririt à cette prudence
mais je pense que oui quand vous
remontez le fil de ces 20 ans il y a eu
tellement d'avertissements il y a eu
tellement de choses qui se sont passées
sur lesquelles on a fermé les yeux c'est
pour ça que j'ai choisi ce titre les
aveuglés euh vous voyez a commencé par
la la la Géorgie l'invasion de la
geéorgie en 2008 ça n'a duré que 5 jours
on était occupé ailleurs il y avait le
c'était au mois d'août il y avait les
Jeux Olympiques à Pékin tous les chefs
d'État étaient là-bas d'ailleurs pour le
l'ouverture et moi aussi d'ailleurs bien
que je ne sois pas chef d'État mais
j'étais là pour le monde et je me disais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
de geéorgie là qui nous gâche la fête
euh mais donc Sarkozy et Bush sont allés
voir Poutine dans les tribunes du stade
à Pékin et lui ont dit parce que c'est
en apprenant on a appris au moment de
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques de la
cérémonie d'ouverture que les troupes
russes étaient entrés en geéorgie et
donc Bush et et et Sarkozi notamment
sont tous les deux allés voir Poutine en
disant mais qu'est-ce que vous faites là
qu'est-ce qui se passe il les a envoyé
balader il leur a dit mais on a été
provoqué vous occupez pas de ça c'est
voilà et donc Bush était en visite
officielle et est resté mais Sarkozi qui
présidait dans la la France présidait
l'Union européenne à ce moment-là est
reparti dès la fin de la cérémonie il
est reparti en France et il a décidé de
négocier un cesser le feu ce qu'il a
fait avec Moscou et etbiss mais c'est un
cesser le feu qui qui en fait s'est fait
selon les termes russes qui qui a donné
satisfaction au russes et qui a permis
au russes de rester encore en geéorgie
de gagner un petit peu plus de terrain
c'était quand même là on on parle de
violation du droit internation en voit
la une hein ils ont franchi la frontière
par le tunnel de de de Rocky là qui qui
par lequel on passe pour passer de
Russie à d'osséti du Nord à océti du Sud
en Georgie et et voilà et on a rien dit
il y a pas eu de sanction la seule chose
qu'on a faite c'était quelques temps
après c'est que la à l'époque la Russie
faisait partie du G7 c'était le G8 et on
l'a exclu du G8 c'est tout et donc à
l'époque on se leure encore en Europe
sur la la vraie nature de oui on se dit
ah on se dit mais c'est la on a toujours
une excuse si vous voulez c'est ça aussi
que j'ai trouvé c'est on trouve toujours
une bonne raison alors là la bonne
raison c'était ça cachevili le président
georgien qui était fougueux voilà et
donc il était tombé dans un piège parce
que les forces gorgienne avait été voilà
il est en prison en Georgie d'ailleurs
ou il il avait les les les les les os
enfin il il y avait eu une espèce de
provocation contre les troupes
geéorgiennes et lui il y est allé avec
avec toute la force l'artillerie et
cetera et du coup ça a donnit le
prétexte aux Russes pour envahir donc
ben c'est la faute de sakashevili il a
il aurait pas dû tomber danse voilà
alors après c'était l'Ukraine en 2014
euh ah bah oui mais l'Ukraine c'est un
pays corrompu c'est des dirigeants qui
sont pas fiable et cetera donc il y
avait toujours bon alors là on est allé
quand même un petit peu plus loin sur
l'annexion de la Crimée l'invasion du
donbas on a pris des sanctions mais on a
au moins pris des sanctions mais c'était
rien François Hollande m'a dit mais ces
sanctions c'était de la gnotte et lui il
était au pouvoiryez donc Angela Merkel
aussi était au pouvoir alors ils ont
essayé de ils ont ils ont mis sur pied
ce format Normandie France Allemagne
Russie Ukraine avec les quatre
présidents enfin Merkel Hollande à
l'époque porosenko et Poutine où ils ont
essayé de négocier ça a pris des années
le processus de Minsk qui se retrouvait
là-bas c'était des heures et des heures
de négociation et les Russes ne ne
bougeaient pas Savit très bien que de
toute façon on a laissé puiser à ça et
pendant ce temps ils menaient leurs
opérations militaires sur le terrain
voyez donc
mh17 hein euh le vol de la Malaysia
airlin 298 morts euh c'était une
d'ailleurs quand je vois l'histoire de
de l'hôpital ça m'y fait penser en à
Gaza donc on a les Russes ont dit oui
oui c'était un missile ukrainien et
cetera bon évidemment c'était pas un
missile ukrainien c'était un missile
russe qu' après avec les images
satellites on a vu que ce ce missile
était passé on l'a vu passer la
frontière et c'est les séparatistes
Ukrainiens qui l'ont pris qui ont
probablement cru abattre un avion
militaire et manque de chance c'était un
avion civil avec 298 personnes à bord
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait des petites
sanctions voyez alors je je vous
interrompes parce que le débat est
quasiment terminé mais je voudrais qu'on
se pose la question de cet aveuglement
est-ce qu'il continue aujourd'hui est-ce
que par exemple Emmanuel Macron qui
continue de enfin qui voulait continuer
de parler avec Vladimir Poutine où en
sont leurs relations aujourd'hui
syvofman parlerait mieux que moi mais je
pense que point mort officiellement un
peu au milieu de de nulle part en tout
cas pour ce qui est de la relation
directe entre les deux hommes il y a pas
eu de grands échanges la dernière
conversation téléphonique à date du 11
septembre 2022 je suis pas sûr qu'il en
est si tôt vous vous souvenez que France
2 avait diffusé un documentaire dans
lequel Emmanuel Macron avait laissé son
haut-parleur ouvert avec une
conversation avec Vladimir Poutine qui
datait d'avant l'invasion d'Ukraine mais
Vladimir Poutine en avait été furieux il
avait jugé ça indécent il avait dit
lorsqu'on téléphone normalement c'est
confidentiel faire le contraire de façon
unilatérale avait-il précisé c'est un
descent bon et puis sur le fond faut
dire que cette discussion
n'aboutissaient pas à grand-chose et les
deux hommes n'avaient plus grand chose à
se dire à part des traditionnelles mises
en garde mais elle permettait c'est vrai
Emmanuel Macron de garder ce fil avec le
maître du crémelin et pourquoi a-t-il
souhaité maintenir ce lien c'est une
vraie question dans un livre Paris au
printemps dernier par publié par une de
vos consceœurs du Figaro elle relate le
coup de fil entre entre Emmanuel Macron
et Vladimir Poutine au lendemain de de
l'invasion en Ukraine tu as pris une
décision historique qui va nous séparer
pendant longtemps dit Emmanuel Macron
j'en prends acte et je ne sais pas quand
on se reparlera et et puis patatra il
lui repasse un coup de fil quelques
semaines juste après il fait exactement
le contraire et en fait depuis son
accession à l'Élysée le président de la
République s'en est s'est fait fort de
tisser un lien personnel avec Vladimir
Poutine on se souvient que c'est quand
même le premier qu'il reçoit en grande
pompe au château de Versailles dès le 29
mai 2017 quand même dès son accession
lisé en gros c'était une façon de
montrer ce que serait sa patte
diplomatique d'aller attraper un Big
Fish comme Vladimir pouti et de montrer
qu'il pouvait lui parler essayer
d'étraîner un nouveau une nouvelle
relation pas comme l'avait fait Sarkozi
ni comm mais voilà de montrer ce que
c'était que le Nouveau Monde et puis il
l'a reçu 2 ans plus tard encore au fort
de brgançon il a dit tiens cette année
Emmanuel Macron à propos vadimir Poutine
quand on le rencontre comme ça il n'est
pas agréable c'est le paradoxe ça il l'a
confié à des journalistes du Papotin
vous savez ce journal c'était c'était au
début de l'année en fait Emmanuel Macron
a cru que ces échanges lui permettrai de
se faire respecter ce qui reste à
prouver parce que Poutine surnommerait
Macron chic qui voudrait dire le le le
petit Macron voilà et puis surtout
Macron a cru que la réalit Réal
politique d'une certaine façon pit qu'il
fallait pas insulter l'avenir vous
souenez cette petite phrase il faut pas
humilier la Russie qui avait évidemment
beaucoup énervé les ukrainien en gros
Emmanuel Macron pense que quand le
moment venu quand il faudra bien se
remettre autour de la table si ce moment
arrive pour parler de paix et ben il
serait au moins en première loge ou au
moins le premier averti le problème
c'est que c'est un scénario qui semble
bien éloigné aujourd'hui CIV Hopman vous
placez Emmanuel Macron parmi les les
aveugles oui enfin les aveuglésug pardon
il a je pense qu'il a été il fait partie
de de ce qui ont été aveuglé mais il a
ouvert les yeux
euhard enfin la la guerre en Ukraine lui
a lu a ouvert les yeux au début de la
guerre en Ukraine il avait propos qui
était pas du tout les propos qu'il a eu
il a changé de d'avis complètement en
cours de route he mais je pense que
maintenant il est et d'ailleurs ce
documentaire dont dont vous parlez à la
fin il y a un
un une interview où où le le réalisateur
lui dit mais finalement vous êtes trompé
enfin la question est pas exactement ça
mais c'est le sens et et il confie il a
vraiment un moment d'hésitation là
Macron il dit oui je j'ai j'ai cru que
avec la confiance on a on on réussirait
à établir une relation de confiance et
intellectuelle des gens dises qu' n'a
pas su lire psychologiquement vladim oui
c'est vrai euh non non c'est c'est c'est
assez étonnant comme relation oui ou oui
ça décharge on peut dire que c'est pas
le seul votre avis là-dessus pour
terminer non mais Emmanuel Macron n'a
pas une une très longue relation avec
Vladimir Poutine Vladimir Poutine
puisque il se maintient au pouvoir de la
façon qu'on connaît et là depuis très
longtemps donc il avait je pense c'est
plutôt avec Angela Merkel qu'on pourrait
comparer temps
d'vir été aveuglé moi je trouve le titre
du livre de Sylvie excellent les
aveuglés parce que c'est c'est tout à
fait ça maintenant on n' pas le temps
mais on pourrait se demander pourquoi
tout le monde a été aveuglé en tout cas
tout le monde a été aveuglé et tout ça
joue absolument en la faveur de Vladimir
Poutine qui s'en amuse follement à
Moscou dire beaucoup à tous Je appel le
titre de vos livres donc CIVI Hoffman
les aveuglés comme en Berlin et Paris
ont laissé la voie libre à la Russie aux
éditions Stock Sylvin can histoire de la
construction européenne depuis 1945
c'est au presse universitaire de France
et puis un continent derrière Poutine y
va aux éditions point poche merci encore
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant note que demain dans la
matinale Oriane mansini reçoit marieise
Léon la secrétaire générale de la CFDT
ce sera à 8h du matin
[Musique]
bસ